This edition of Scout Mash Podcast is brought to you by the folks at Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They aren't scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prices for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom.
That's C-O-N-O-H-O-Creakcom.
And now the old scout master.
Hey, we were out cabin camping last weekend.
We went to light the stove and a mouse jumped out of it.
We tried to catch him but unfortunately he was out of range.
It only gets better from here, folks. Don't worry.
This is podcast number 169..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag here. Francine wrote in about last week's podcast
And she said it's another great podcast.
I had a similar problem with blue cards when a council summer camp
issued completed merit badges on a computer printout versus the blue card.
I simply had scouts put their information on blue cards,
stapled a copy of the forms the camp gave us to the blue card for our records,
supplied the scout with their portion of the blue card with another copy of the form on it.
It was a pretty quick, easy solution to the problem
And we know that the official blue card. that application for a merit badge
is supposed to be the only accepted form.
Some people get it wrong once in a while.
We don't make the scouts suffer,
We try and find a way to solve it.
Francine, it sounds like you found a way.
Thank you very much for letting us know.
Alan Schneider is the scout master of troop 483..
He said I enjoyed your segment on patrols planning menus that one scout doesn't like.
I've had new scouts come into the troop
and it seems like their parents allow them to be picky eaters
and they prepare their own meals for them and things like that,
which is really almost impossible for a patrol to deal with.
But if they work at it they find a way.
If a patrol works with a scout who's got a problem with the menu,
they learn to adjust their habits as a patrol
and the scout himself learns something.
Actually, by the end of the first year in scouts, one mom came to me
and said she couldn't believe her son was now eating so many different meals
that she'd never been able to get him to eat before.
Well, you know what,
When you don't have a whole lot of choices,
sometimes you adjust your menu a little bit.
You adjust what's acceptable to eat,
and a patrol can work around that,
And it's surprising what kind of solutions they come up with
when we put the problem in their hands.
They'll need a little advice
and things usually end up working out, don't they?
Thanks for getting in touch, Alan. I do appreciate it.
Kim Jones is the committee chair of troops 723 in Placentia, California,
And she wrote in to say
I get all of the scoutmastercgcom emails.
I'm a subscriber and I really enjoy them
and I found so many very timely.
As a committee chair, I do my best to support our scoutmaster
and his assistants.
I find your ideas and viewpoints refreshing and informed.
I'm sad that everyone can enjoy scouting.
I did work with a gay cubmaster
and she was the best things those kids could ask for.
What really matters is what's inside,
how we treat scouts and how we set an example for them.
Keep those emails coming.
I'm truly a fan and I appreciate all the hard work you have done
and still do for scouting.
Well, thank you so much, Kim.
I appreciate the vote of confidence
and I'm glad you're finding things useful,
And I really appreciate you getting in touch.
John Fox wrote in to say that he's been following the blog for a while
and he likes the new ideas that he sometimes finds there,
And he wants to put the three phrases for scoutmasters
on the back of his Unit Commissioner business card.
and you go right ahead, John, Feel free.
Those three phrases you're going to hear again
a little later on in the podcast.
I'll tell you about that in just a second.
Before I get too far ahead of myself,
let me remind you that May 12th- Sunday, May 12th-
is our next Scout Circle. It'll be about summer camp.
We have a camp director who's going to be our guest
and he'll be talking about summer camp
and different programs and things.
Plus, you'll be able to ask questions
and get them answered in a live presentation situation.
Go to scoutscircleorg.
That's going to happen Sunday, May 12th,
from 9 to 10 pm Eastern Daylight Time
at scoutscircleorg.
I also want to mention that we have a YouTube channel. now
I'm aiming at a weekly video
that is kind of, you know, catching you up
on the blog and the podcast.
Plus, they'll feature reviews of camping gear
and other useful things for scout leaders.
So go over to YouTube,
Look for scoutmasterscgcom,
and let me thank those of you who've subscribed
to our new YouTube channel and left comments
and who are looking at the videos there.
I really do appreciate it.
The rest of the podcast is taken up with this month's
installment of the Colorado experiment.
If you joined us last month, you know that we've got-
we're watching- a brand new scout master
and a brand new troop being formed out in Colorado,
And it's been very, very interesting.
And this time around we'll be talking about
patrol leaders' council meetings,
And we also managed to isolate three phrases
that I think will be very useful to you
as a scout master or a scouting volunteer.
So, hey, without further ado, let's get started, shall we?
And now our next episode of the Colorado experiment.
This is our second installment of the Colorado experiment.
I love the idea that it's an experiment
That's awesome,
And that's Arlen Ward,
And he's out there in Colorado
And the experiment is, I think, at one point,
Arlen. we call it jumping into the volcano.
Yeah,
I think that's an apt description, as
I think it was Walter that said:
you're just not ever the same after you jump into the volcano.
Right,
In case you haven't been following the story,
jumping into the volcano is a euphemism we're using
for becoming a scout master.
And not only is Arlen a brand new scout master,
but he's also got a brand new troop
And we talked a little bit the last time we were together
last month about how that came together
And we've been talking a little bit here
before we started recording.
but, Arlen, you've had your first patrol leader's council meeting.
Yeah,
So actually we've had two PLC meetings
because we've kind of worked our way through the first month,
which has been interesting.
So who is at this patrol leader's council meeting
that you're having?
Well, the very first one we had,
we had talked to a number of scouts of different ages
and we had two older, 16 year old life scouts
that said that they really liked the idea of starting a troop
and setting the tone and the culture of the troop
from the beginning,
And so we had the two of them was really the first meeting
that we had.
Obviously, from your experience level and your age
and your interest in really setting this,
I would like you to be involved
in leadership positions in the troop
And so why don't you join us one night
and we'll sit here and we'll talk about it?
So it was myself, the committee chair,
one of the assistant scout masters.
We kind of sat together on one end
and then there was these two life scouts
that sat together on the other side
And these two guys are great.
They have known each other since Tiger Cubs
are great friends.
They know a lot about scouting
and what's been going on in their own experience.
The troop is still kind of in this formative stages.
Is one of these guys your senior patrol leader now,
or have you formalized anything like that?
That was one of the first things that came up
that I was like: okay, this is definitely not my troop,
It's up to them, because that's what I had said to them.
I said: the two of you,
or what do you want to do with regards to troop level leadership?
And they talked about it for a little bit
and they came back to me and said:
we want to be co-senior patrol leaders.
And the committee chair looked at me: can they do that?
I was like I've never heard of it,
I've never seen it, but I don't see why not.
I said you have to be prepared for the time
that the two of you don't agree on something.
And they seemed rather unconcerned with that.
But I said: yeah, I have no problem with that.
If you want to both be senior patrol leader,
knock yourself out.
There will be elections and whatnot
at some point in the future.
This is the way that they wanted to move forward.
You're comfortable with that?
Yes,
Okay,
I didn't see a reason to stand in their way.
I should point out to everybody
that should be everybody's watchword right there.
I didn't see a reason to stand in their way.
That would be a really good place to start.
So it's not worrying you that this isn't following
some pattern that maybe you had in your mind
or the other adults had in their mind?
Are you guys overly concerned about having elections
or formalizing things a little bit more,
so it looks like the book,
Or are you comfortable with moving forward this way?
When we talked about it initially,
I said: if it doesn't work, we can always change it,
And as it sits now
we are looking at the first set of elections a year out-
The size of a troop. there's plenty of leadership opportunities.
I'm not worried about anybody not having their six months
for whatever advancement that they need.
I want to capture one other phrase.
The first phrase is:
I didn't really see any reason to stand in their way,
And the second one is:
if it doesn't work out, we can change it.
Yeah,
And neither one of those are unique phrases
that I came up with
And I learned all this stuff from you,
from other scoutmasters.
There's a scoutmaster in our area that I had mentioned last time.
I invited us down to talk about his program
and what they do in their troop,
And one of the things in Wood Badger they talk about
is the stages of team development.
If you significantly change the sort of thing that you're doing,
you go through those same stages all over again.
So we have some idea of the dynamic
of the relationship with the adults
and these youth leaders.
Right now you're working with two pretty motivated youth leaders
and who are excited at the prospect of what's happening.
What are the adults doing
at the Petroleum Council meeting?
Honestly, I think that was probably a mistake
to have them there.
Now, why do you say that
They stepped in? probably a little bit more than I would have,
Just providing answers rather than asking questions.
You don't have a transcript of the meeting, obviously,
As that dialogue was going on.
give me an idea of what you consider to be like
outside of the bounds of what you would like to have happen.
Well, I can kind of give you the whole dynamic of that
in one topic,
And this shows that these two scouts
aren't any different than anybody else's. I guess
They had brought up uniforms.
Well, what are we going to do about uniforms?
And we started talking about it in general terms
and one of them said: you know,
I was kind of hoping that we wouldn't need uniforms.
He's 16 years old.
I remember being a scout at 16..
I wasn't entirely enthused about wearing the scout uniform
then either.
And at that point
someone else said: look, we've got to.
There's no question.
You have to have a uniform,
You have to wear the uniform.
We have to set the standard of uniform
And just lay down the law of that's out of the question
that we don't have uniforms.
It became more of a discussion rather than
you will have uniforms and more of a.
This is why we do this.
So, looking at that issue,
the scouts raised a question.
Instead of giving them a policy statement
as an answer,
what I'm hearing from you is that you looked at it
as an opportunity to have a little bit more
of a wider ranging discussion
in which they were able to discover
the reason for something,
rather than just being told: well, this is the way that it is,
And I'm not saying that it was entirely
blue sky and easy going and that it was all my way
by the time they didn't completely come around
to my point of view.
What was the outcome of either these patrol leaders
council meetings?
Do you have a full calendar of meetings all set up
and outings all planned?
We have about three months' worth of activities planned
and we have an idea,
a general idea, of what's going to be covered
in those meetings.
More detail in the things that are in the near term,
the next couple of weeks,
much less what's going on in June and July.
Well, we were talking before. you mentioned
the attitude towards these guys
as far as troop meetings go.
What was that discussion?
They didn't like just having meetings for a meeting's sake,
And so for the new scouts that we have
that have never been hiking,
what do they need to know?
It was my part of that discussion
and what came out of that?
one of these guys said:
well, you know, sometimes when we go hiking,
some people bring way too much stuff
and some people hardly bring anything at all.
And that was quite literally what he said.
They said: well, okay,
so what should we cover to correct that?
And they brought up the 10 essentials
and said if we're going to go hiking,
we should talk about the 10 essentials.
It was like, well, fantastic,
It works out much better that way
than me setting it and saying:
we're going to cover the 10 essentials,
You're going to teach it this way.
We started from what's the need
and worked backwards from there.
You knew what you wanted to do
to get everybody ready to go on the hike.
I had a general idea.
Yeah,
And you probably included in that
general idea somewhere the specific
of stuff to bring,
like 10 essentials and things like that.
But you didn't tell these guys
that that's what they were supposed to do.
No, because at that point it goes back
to what they were complaining about
from their previous experience,
which is: you're going to teach knots tonight
And one of them says: you know,
I'm tired of teaching the little kids
Right
After four years doing that.
he doesn't want to do that.
But if you phrase it as
we're going to go hiking, what should we do?
What comes out of that is:
well, I guess there are things that they have to
be prepared for.
If we're all going to go hiking
and we're going to have a good time,
they need to know the 10 essentials.
What interests me really is
the way that you enter
into the whole conversation there.
If the scout master sits down
and says: you know,
we're going on a hike and here are the five
things that you need to do to get everybody
ready for the hike,
That's a very different thing
when you're sitting down and saying,
what are we doing? Oh, we're going on a hike,
So what are you going to do to get everybody ready
to go on the hike?
And letting that question
fill in the blanks rather than
the scout master filling in the blanks.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah,
That's repeated over and over again
as we've gone through this
A couple of iterations. now
You know we're getting ready for our first
camping trip and the camping trip
is the same meeting
when we were first talking about
what activities should we do.
We want to do something this month,
but we don't have a lot of time to prepare,
so let's do the hiking trip.
The next one was: I think
we should have a camp out
where everybody gets to know each other,
because I don't know a lot of these guys
just going camping to hang out
and figure out who we're camping with,
And that was their idea.
Then let out of. that was
like really good food,
A lot of good eating and hanging out
If we're going to do a good food.
that to me leads to
questions around Dutch ovens
And they're like: yeah, let's bring the Dutch ovens,
We can do dinners out of that.
It's a great opportunity for us
to show off the types of food
that you can have on a camping trip.
So we picked a date for that camping trip
and then roughly said
we've got four meetings before the camping trip.
There's going to be things that we need to cover
around:
what to bring,
how to cook
certain things.
They filled in kind of rough ideas around that.
The Monday after our hike,
we had our second PLC meeting
where we said: alright, our next activity
according to the schedule you guys put out
is this camping trip,
And what kind of detail
do we need to actually get into these
meetings along the way?
And so
we're getting into things of how to pack
a backpack, how to
set up the dining fly,
Things like that,
And so those are the things that they're going to
cover in the upcoming meetings.
Let me ask you this- Answer this as honestly
as you can:
Who's leading and who's following
in these two meetings that you described to me?
Yeah, I would say
I've been leading
that discussion.
I'm the one that brings up the questions.
I'll be facilitating the discussion.
Okay,
Who's getting the last say decision-making wise
as far as
what they're up to and how they're going to make it
happen
They are?
Who's going to do what?
What all are we covering in the meetings?
Every once in a while, I'll bring up some administrative
things that we need to get taken care of.
Our very first meeting,
in addition to covering the 10 essentials,
the other thing we were supposed to cover-
or they were supposed to cover- was
getting patrols set up.
But Mother Nature intervened and
on the night of our very first troop meeting,
we got 14 inches of snow
in our neighborhood.
So they decided
that they didn't want to set up the patrols. yet
They said: we don't have enough guys here
to divide up into
what they want to do. I was like, okay,
that's fine,
I said, but that is something that we need to get done,
especially before we go camping,
since these guys are going to be cooking as a group,
they're going to need to figure out what they're doing.
The one thing that I haven't heard anything
about in the discussion thus far
are things like advancement
or requirements
or anything like that.
There's this voice that every Monday is in my head
that tells me
that
scouts advance when they do
the things that scouts do.
And it's
come up repeatedly and I've written it down
and tried to keep that in mind
And I've even used that
phrasing to describe it to the scouts.
I mean because I have parents
of scouts that have said, well,
in the last trip they were and they did
merit badges and troop
meetings and we need to figure out
which merit badges they're going to do in troop meetings.
I was like, well, I kind of made a face
because I can tell you're not really a big fan
of that.
I said no.
I said troop meetings are preparing for outings
but merit badges have nothing to do with that.
I said merit badges are interesting
and I think as a troop we certainly should
offer opportunities to do merit badges.
I said if we want to set up,
if we've got enough interest from a group of scouts
that they all want to do,
say the first aid merit badge is a group.
I know merit badge counselors,
we can set it up and we can set it up on some time.
that's not.
but what I left it with
was we can go to the PLC with it
and see what they want to do.
I said, well, we've got to decide what merit badges happen
at troop meetings.
This was another adult
and you said, well,
we'll go to the patrolers council and see what they have to say.
What kind of reaction did you get from the adult
They
understood-
That was why they
had moved to this troop in the first place-
was we're giving them leadership
opportunities.
and when we get together
with a group of these parents and we talk,
often it comes up,
from my perspective,
it's not so much what we're doing
but who's doing it.
And that
just kind of brought that home.
It's like, okay, yeah,
as a committee
or as a scout master
and as few assistant scout masters,
we could figure that out,
but at that point it goes back to
them running
a program that somebody else handed to them.
I think that a lot of people who are in your position
would be looking at the book
and they would be thinking about advancement,
they would be thinking about setting up patrols,
they would be thinking about
the leadership chart
and everything.
You just don't seem to be overly concerned
with that stuff.
Don't get me wrong. I've
been through that book many times.
look through the requirements
and all of those pieces.
when it comes to this first
camping trip that we've got,
since we're taking Dutch ovens
and things like that, we're not going to be that far from the car
and so I had brought up
with the,
the PLC said, look, since we're
already hauling a bunch of stuff and we're not,
this isn't going to be much of a
the way of a backpacking trip.
what about bringing the axes and the saws along
and teaching
the totem chip
and the knife safety and the axe yard
and all of that stuff? that,
from my standpoint, I don't see us having a lot
of opportunity to do
when we're doing much in the way of
backcountry things.
and they're like, yeah, that would be good,
that's the sort of activity that
they could see doing
as they're getting to know each other.
and so
we talked about that for a little bit
and they were in agreement that
that we could
do the knife safety stuff.
and that stems out of me looking
through the book and seeing the requirements
for second class
and tender foot, that
safe handling of a knife.
I explained to these guys a fire starting competition
and they looked at me all confused.
I said, look, you know you have two stakes in the ground.
you put a string across here and a string across
a little bit higher, and you can't stack wood
any higher than the bottom one and the first one to burn
through the top string wins. you know
they looked at me and said I've never heard of that before.
and you're seeing them
respond to this way of doing
things with
a good amount of energy and engagement.
yeah, yeah, I think
they have more questions than anything else
at this point and I
do see
from the parents
some concern that things aren't moving
as fast as they would like.
but I think that's going to be a continuous thing,
that the
scouts are always going to have more questions
and some
lack of assurance that
these things are going to
take care of themselves along the way,
and the parents are always going to be
wishing things were a little bit more organized
and perhaps we had a six month calendar
instead of a
month and a half calendar.
those are going to keep coming up and
as long as we keep on the message
of:
yes, I understand
that your family is busy and we will do our best
to get a longer range calendar
put together, but
it's going to be rather nebulous
in the first bit
and the reason that it's going to be nebulous is because
you're invested in
letting the guys find their own way
rather than
giving them a menu of stuff to work with.
I could sit down
in three hours and lay out
a year's worth of activities
and meeting plans
for a scout troop.
we do that for the Cub Scout pack all the time.
we call it our
annual planning meeting.
the adults sit in a room and we
lay out what we're going to do next year.
we pick the dates for everything
and what the activities are going to be
at each monthly pack meeting and stuff like that.
but this is different.
this is, again, not so much about
what we're doing, more about who's doing it.
okay, so now I've got three phrases,
so let's see.
the first one was:
I didn't see any reason to stand in their way,
and then the second one
was: if it doesn't work, we can change it
right.
and the third one was: yeah, we used to do that all the time
for the Cub Scouts.
yes,
I like it.
okay. so
our kind of standard three
questions. what worked really well,
what worked better than
I ever thought it would,
is turning to the Scouts
and saying:
what do you think?
whatever the topic was:
I've got
the second PLC meeting.
we sat down and one of these guys looked at me
and said: I think we need to go to summer camp.
and we had decided as adults:
it's
going to be a month after we start the troop,
we'll just camp through this summer
and then we'll go to summer camp next year.
and they're like, yeah, but I just think we need to go somewhere
and we need to get these guys into a summer camp
and spend a week.
and I couldn't argue with that.
I know,
I'm all for it.
so we've made some phone calls
and done some research and found a number of camps
that have space still
and we'll take them back to them
and say, look, this is what's out there.
what do you guys want to do with it?
is there anything that
just absolutely fell flat
and you thought it was a great idea
but it just didn't get anywhere?
anytime we're traveling anywhere,
we should be in full uniform
would fall into that category.
100%.
the very first outing we had.
I'm sitting there going. do I show up
in my uniform? I told them
that we were going to go everywhere in you,
but I don't see how this is going to work.
as Murphy's Law of Combat says
no plan ever survives initial contact,
and that's what happened here.
the funny thing is that was mine.
that was my vision
of what the troop should be.
I was the one that
the PLC meeting said I would really like to see this
and they went: okay, fine,
it lets you have that one.
and it didn't work.
but at the second PLC meeting-
that's what I told them-
this was a great idea, I thought,
turns out not so much. and they all nodded
and said, yeah,
what would you change?
what would you have done differently
over the past month?
I think a lot of the families
are
still really starved for information.
I think we didn't explain early enough
in this to some families
that this is what it's going to look like.
from a parent's perspective.
it's going to seem kind of
haphazard
and it's going to seem rather
like we're throwing things together at the last minute.
but a lot of that's coming from.
I am really resisting
the urge to lay out the plan
and letting them do it,
and they're not going to do it
more than a month in advance.
we can get the activities on the calendar
further out than that
and maybe, as we work forward
a few months into this,
maybe they'll get faster at it.
but we can spend an hour and a half
talking about
what's going to happen in the next month
as we move away from having adults
involved in that PLC
and they start asking those questions
or coming prepared with answers to them.
they're going to get better at it
and that communication is going to come along.
but I got families
that look at this and say
I wish I knew more
about what's going on.
so do I?
yes, absolutely.
Is there anything I've missed
that you would hope to talk about?
There's been some surprises along the way.
the weather has definitely
made sure that we're flexible.
we've had to
readjust locations for things
and kind of goals
for meetings when not everybody can get there,
and we're still struggling
with the fact that we don't have a set
meeting place yet. so
we're seeing if we can
move up that calendar a little bit
with our meeting
place or just finding another
organization
or a community center or something where we can meet
instead of meeting in houses.
and that was again
brought up by the PLC,
those guys saying: look
from our perspective, this is where things sit
right now. Arlen, I really appreciate you talking
with me and we'll do this again
next month and we'll see exactly
how you're doing.
Yeah, hopefully by then I can tell you all about
how these guys are expert campers
and can plan things six months in advance.
and
the emails and parents have stopped
asking any questions.
Well, if that happens, I'm moving to Colorado.
Yes, fair warning.
It's been an interesting
initial contact,
for all of us for sure.
Thanks so much
for listening to this
edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. Here's how you can
keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster
blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
there by email. You can also
subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes and when you do,
please feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating. You can
access the podcast on any mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
You can get details about
how to make that happen at stitchercom.
and if you just can't
get enough, there's always
the vast panorama of
social media outlets. That's right.
We're Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Scoutmaster CG
on Twitter and we do have
the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle.
if you look for us on
Google Plus Plus, we have
a YouTube channel now. Look for Scoutmaster
CG and
wow, you can not only hear,
but you can watch us in action. How about
that? You can always
zoom into the late 90's
and send me your comments
and questions via
email- the miracle of
email. I'm at
Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
at
ScoutmasterC-G
com.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
It's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and group camping.
Thank you, sir, Until next time.